I think most of us dread Mondays because
culturally we've learned to dread
Mondays.
We live for the weekend.
Our music is,
you know,
celebrates Fridays better than Monday.
Our movies celebrate Fridays better than
Monday.
Um,
and,
and maybe our parents did too.
I think there was a generation that
didn't have the same freedoms you and I
have.
Um,
30 years ago,
40 years ago,
I couldn't have this conversation where
I could say to the camera to everybody
watching,
hey,
you have a chance to plug into a
community that will help you.
You didn't,
how would you even find those people in
1960?
How has your mom or your dad going to
find a community of other people,
other photographers,
other artists,
other bankers,
other anything's easily,
they couldn't.
So I think we have access to people and
tools and experiences that no other
generation had access to.
And so in addition to that being a huge
opportunity,
it's a huge responsibility.
We have a chance to break that mold of a
job is just the job.
Monday is horrible and Friday is great.
What if we got to reinvent that?
What if we got to rescue Mondays and
that doesn't mean be fake.
I'm not saying tomorrow turn a frown
upside down.
No,
I'm much more practical than that.
You're going to have some difficult
days,
some Tuesdays that aren't fun.
There's no such thing as a perfect job.
That's one of the things that cripples
people.
They think I have to find the perfect
job where I only do things I want to do
and that doesn't exist.
But what if you could say,
okay,
can I use more of me at my next job?
Can I use more of me on a Monday?
Then I got to a week ago?
Can I use more of the things I'm good
at?
Can I start to look forward to going to
work?
Can I start to look forward to a
Wednesday and not just live in this
culture that only celebrates Friday?
I don't want us to have a life where we
feel like Tim Robbins at the end of
Shawshank redemption as we drive away
from work on Friday,
this sense of relief.
Finally I got out of that because here's
the thing that's really bad math and
here's what I mean by that.
Somebody,
many saying to you,
we'll give you two weeks of vacation and
exchange.
We want you to give us 50 weeks.
This year.
50 for two is terrible math trading.
50 weeks of misery for two weeks of
vacation is bad math trading.
Five days you don't like for two days.
You do like again is bad math training,
40 years of your life.
I mean,
that's the thing.
That's why I write about career.
You're going to do this thing for 40
years,
40 to 60 hours a week.
Let's invest in it.
Let's make it as good as it can be.
Let's make it as awesome as it can be
because it matters.
We're talking about four decades of your
life.
Certainly we should lean into that.
Okay.